Lamar Odom says he no longer wants Khloe  Kardashian back of keep our distance the  former NBA star appeared on the Wendy  Williams Show Wednesday and didn't hold  back when asked if he would ever get  back with his ex-wife no and I say that  like we're no offense to hood that would  be the best for both of us yes keep our  distance the 37 year old also opened up  about the current status of his  friendship with former brother-in-law  Rob Kardashian I mean we will close the  two were tight friends Rob even lived  with Khloe and Lamar for a few years hey  how's it say oh I have a minister isn't  it so what happened between the two  I guess it's maybe because I heard his  sister too much oh I have no I've no v  no idea I mean if she was my brother I  would have a problem that means you when  if she was my sister  [Music]